I'm not saying that religion can't ever
be useful or inspire good things,
it's certainly can and has and,
and will,
and that's,
that's a better than the alternative,
but there's a distinction we have to
recognize there's a distinction between
something being true and so they'd been
useful and every religion,
every benign religion,
every religion that's actually helping
somebody sometimes could be functioning
like a placebo.
I mean,
it could be,
it could be totally barren of content
and still useful in certain
circumstances.
I couldn't invent a religion right now
which we know is not true and would be
extremely useful if I could spread it to
billions invented right now.
Just this religion is,
um,
the principles are,
do your best to love your neighbor and
you and your family and every person you
meet,
uh,
encourage your children to study science
and mathematics to the best of their
abilities.
Um,
and if you don't do this,
you will be punished for eternity by 17
demons after death.
Now,
I have no doubt that if I could spread
this to billions,
this would be a better religion than the
religions we've got.
It will be better than Christianity and
Judaism and Islam.
You'd have no suicide bombers.
What you would have is a generation of
children bearing down on science and
mathematics to the best of their
abilities,
encouraged by their otherwise ethical
parents all under the the compulsion of
do this or else the 17 demons will
torture you for eternity.
Does this with the usefulness of this?
I mean this.
We would,
we would live in a much better world.
No question.
The usefulness of this.
Would this suggest for a moment that
these 17 demons actually exist?
Would it,
would it provide a reason to believe in,
in these 17 demons,
a not even slightly.
So that's,
that's the divide here.
There's,
there's,
there's a big difference between the
utility of an idea or the consoling
nature of an idea.
I mean,
the idea that God has a plan for me or
everything happens for a reason,
and the idea that these are consoling is
quite distinct from whether there are
good reasons to believe right.